uh the next thing we want to talk about
Riker what do you think uh well so we
have all these legendary items one
semi-deterministic way to farm for them
hell tied it's an activity where well I
guess you can dive into how exactly you
can Target Farms specific item slots to
hunt for specific unique items and it's
going to be one of the main endgame
activities that we'll be partaking in
right yeah absolutely so as I mentioned
before once the player gains access to
nightmare torment here uh they are going
to a nightmare tier they're gonna start
getting they're gonna start seeing some
of these new activities one of them
which is hellside uh hellside is
basically going to be uh switch for you
you know as you're running through the
world of sanctuary you know the sky
turns red blood begins to fall from the
sky new monsters begin to appear
everything is more challenging new like
events are going to start showing up and
importantly as you're killing creatures
while you're within one of these
hell-tied areas you're gonna be getting
what we call Cinders it's this new
currency player build to collect while
they're specifically Within These spaces
and this is great because you get to
take these Cinders and as you're
wandering through the Overworld might be
running on your other players uh you
might be like helping them do events
together everyone's getting their own
centers as they go uh you'll be looking
for these hell type caches you can see
here and these are great to your point
about being able to Target farm for
certain kinds of items so every one of
the caches in the hell tied zone is
actually tied to an item slot and they
all have different costs so you look
kind of like you'll be gathering centers
by playing within this space trying to
locate one of the caches that have the
item type that you're looking for
whether like maybe you're looking for
amulet or looking for a ring you know
maybe you're looking maybe you're
looking for a Shaco so you're looking
actually to go find a helmet cache and
want to keep trying to go after the
helmet cash and the rare desperate hope
you're going to get exactly the unique
item that you're looking for right
that's cool we want to give you some of
that opportunity to give you that
opportunity Target farmer a little bit
but there's actually a little bit of fun
there too uh so one of the things that's
like one of my personal favorite parts
of the helter system is the idea that
the uh the player is the Players uh
there's like an extra set of stakes
right when the players running around
these Cinders uh they have the chance
that they if they die they're going to
lose about half of their senders every
time they they fall they don't they
don't drop on the ground they're gone so
you have to be very care careful about
like when you're looking to overextend
as part of the combat experience in
order to like Farm more Cinders get to
the cash that you're looking for
whatever that is you are putting
yourself at more risk the more you try
to like gather and the greater you get
the more likely it is that you're going
to lose things that's right and there's
a time limit on paltai too right that's
right health is only active like the the
force of hell when we like arrive for
about like about an hour uh during uh
when they are actually active and
different areas of sanctuary are picked
for uh for a helicized Zone each time it
rotates and moves around so you need to
make good use of your uh your power and
you if you leave a hellside Zone those
Cinders are gone you have to you have to
spend them so if you see that the clock
is ticking down you're getting five or
four or three minutes away from the end
of the hillside you've got to find
yourself a cash to kind of deposit those
things
yeah absolutely my experience I first
jumped into a hell tied event with I
think 23 minutes left on the clock so I
start by okay I'm scouting out the
different uh chests or or caches uh to
set to see okay which is the one that
has the the slot that I'm looking for
what are the different costs and then
I'm doing some quick math okay I'm
gathering Cinders at about this rate per
minute I have this many minutes left
okay I think I could afford the the most
expensive the weapon slot and I gotta
backtrack to that place in order to get
there
and then I died and like okay
recalculating yeah uh okay how much time
do I have left now okay
yeah and then I died again and like good
luck next time well another hour before
the next one comes around I'll have a
better plan this time now granted you
can still get legendary items to drop
for you to sort of get really good drops
inside hell tied experiences and while
you're killing monsters so it's not like
if you lose those Sinners you've lost
all opportunities for rewards but
obviously it does take a little wind out
of your sales if you just happen to get
jumped at the wrong time again another
great opportunity for there'll be
players nearby when they're trying to
help uh help out in those situations
yeah you know one of the things I think
is really cool about this is that the so
the these uh chats are caches boxes with
lewd and awesome loot inside right
um they uh you know each time a hell
tied appears they appear they're in
different locations right so you you
have to go and find them you know as
Riker was saying
um but within for the duration of that
hell tied they're in fixed places so you
know when you go into the hellside area
it's you useful to scout out and see
where the caches are for the item spots
that you're interested in and then you
can you know mentally remember okay I
want to farm around here I'm going to
come back here I'm going to get this
this item or or whatever and one thing I
want to call out here um you know you
you saw one of the caches on the the
screen earlier you know in in some of
our video that we captured for it now we
did capture that with the uh the UI off
so you can't see the the icon above it
but there is an icon that says in here
there are boots that's correct you don't
know before you open that cache uh
what's in it I mean that's not all I
mean there's uh there's other risks in
dangers inherent in Hell tied areas uh
you know this is an opportunity for you
to bite some like some different bosses
again like I mentioned before there are
different events and things that
actually are going to be showing up uh
and of course we can't really have such
a such a wonderful experience as hell
without our baby boy the butcher showing
up occasionally and causing serious uh
Mayhem and Mischief uh in the the
Overworld of sanctuary so lots of really
fun things happen inside these Hillside
areas over the course of the players
experience and it's also an opportunity
to farm a special crafting material
right uh that's correct there are craft
materials like fiend Rose and things
that really are coming directly from
Hell tied Encounters in those
experiences so you are looking to also
get some of the materials you need for
like really high tier uh like weapon and
item upgrades from going through these
uh these places
so Health ad is what we're doing to farm
crafting materials in order to Target
Farm specific drops another big activity
that we're going to be doing nightmare
dungeons you want to talk a bit about
that yeah so yeah Joe do you have
anything you want to talk about products
you know nightmare dungeons are we we're
going to talk again we're going to talk
about beta feedback at the end of the
the show here
um or near near the end of the show but
uh nightmare dungeons are our key
dungeon replayability system for the
later part of the game right
um and you're going to get sigils and
Joe's going to talk a little bit about
the sigils but uh we're really excited
for players to get to check out all of
the cool ways that the dungeons can
really be transformed uh by the
nightmare dungeon system yeah so uh so
first up Emir dungeons very very
exciting system please I haven't had a
chance to play these in our betas yet
but as they get into the uh the end game
contents are going through World tiers
three and four you'll begin to see uh
you'll gain access to some of your first
sigils which are primarily in initially
earned by completing Whispers of the
Dead one of our other Overworld content
copies employers build engage with now
uh sigils are really interesting in that
they are tied to a level when you find
them which is going to affect the level
of the monsters inside that space they
have various afflictions which we talked
to talk a little bit about in streams in
the past uh these are going to modify
the way that that level rolls out but
nightmare sigils when they are activated
when you after you collect one is going
to basically open up a portal near an
existing side dungeon and uh with every
in the pre-release version of Diablo 4
in additional Seasons we basically
select a subset of all the side dungeons
of the game that can become nightmare
dungeons for that period so players
become become more familiar with a set
number of these because they know that
they can be populated with these
nightmare dungeon experiences so you
might already know whether it's Annex
claim or whatever it is what the layout
what the layout of a given dungeon might
look like normally but a nightmare
nightmare sigil is going to change that
by introducing these new afflictions and
then also these greater Reflections we
showed earlier in the video like this uh
right now actually we're looking at a
this uh uh this help World a nightmare
Pearl that can open up and basically
spawn in all these Monsters uh from
other like monster families it might not
be native to that dungeon which is
pretty cool and that we like we like the
idea that players are going to have to
kind of deal with these new different
threats and what they're typically used
to and so as part of part of that
encounter and there's a number of these
other like greater afflictions like we
showed the uh storm Banes wrath that
again that disc thing that was flowing
around behind around your occasionally
it just pulses out this really big
stunning damaging effect so you have to
be mindful of where it is so you should
make sure you avoid it as part of the
combat experience definitely adds a new
wrinkle to gameplay as you're going
through and we add more of these
afflictions as the player continues to
level up and they get to go deeper and
deeper into the the nightmare essential
system I get unlocking higher level
sigils and dealing with like more and
more dangerous threats over the course
of time and this is a this is a really
great place not only just to uh to like
an experience and really push your build
and make sure that you're uh you're
strong enough to tackle these sorts of
challenges but you'll also be able to
these are really great places to farm
for like sacred and ancestral items in
particular and uh these are the places
you're gonna be upgrading your Paragon
glyphs we'll be talking more about the
Paragon system right now so
and that like this is an opportunity to
show the actual upgrade lip screen I
just noticed like Hey look it's actually
up right now what what timing um so yeah
when the player reaches the end of a
nightmare dungeon they get to basically
go ahead and take one of the glyphs
they've been collecting over the course
of their uh their 50 plus experience and
basically uh slot into here and choose
to upgrade it and make that glyph even
more powerful these sockables will go on
your Paragon board and end up being some
of the single most powerful modifiers
you can apply to your character above
legendary powers and even in some cases
even above some unique powers so it's
really in your benefit based on your
build to be choosing uh looking for a
set number of these and upgrade them to
exactly what you need them to do
okay
and the uh so the sigils that we're
getting uh
what I noticed is that if you get some
afflictions that you don't particularly
care about we have the ability to
salvage some in order to craft centrals
of our own right I think it's a four to
one ratio is that right yeah just about
so you'll be able to get a lot of these
different signals by going through
nightmare dungeons completing Whispers
and other through other content if
you're finding socials that you don't
really want or don't really want to run
because maybe it's we're gonna have like
enemies inside you're gonna do
additional lightning damage but you
don't have a lot of lightning resist on
your build maybe you want to go ahead
and like Salvage that back at the
occultist take that down so it's digital
dust and use that to basically make new
random Essentials for you to go ahead
and run with this is ways for players to
kind of like you know push themselves a
little further they'll unlock higher
level signals they can craft through the
system over the course of time and uh
just uh it's another way to kind of like
re-utilize the messages you might not be
as interested in running from time to
time you know one thing I liked about
the afflictions was it was making me
make choices during the gameplay like
two that I can speak to they the
nightmare Gates that we were just
showcasing
let's say I'm in the middle of fighting
an elite and I'm almost taking him down
I see that nightmare portal opening and
I'm like okay should I take care of that
before it starts spawning more monsters
or do I finish this fight first I'm
forced to make a decision and I gotta
live with the consequences if I think
you know maybe I should take him down
and then know the fight becomes more
challenging and nope I should have taken
care of that gate first another one is I
forget the name but it's it's some kind
of blood cyst that starts to grow grow
and then if you just don't touch it it
eventually explodes in a huge area yeah
and it's either okay destroy it before
it does that or get the heck away as
fast as possible again
um making choices and it's like okay I
think I I had I thought I had time to
get away then I got crowd controlled and
then boom one shot so I like how it
changes the dungeon experience depending
on which of these afflictions that you
you get yeah absolutely there's death
counts in some of these as well as time
goes on you get into the deeper ones
whether you gotta be careful you can't
choose just throw yourselves at these
things and if you're making mistakes you
have to really evaluate carefully how
you're progressing
all right
that's true so yeah you got a chance to
play through some of those uh so yeah
never done is very exciting and they'll
go up Beyond level 100 as well actually
so uh this is this is a content type
that you can actually fight up to
creatures up to level 150 actually as
part of the experience based on how how
far you're able to push yourself as time
goes on so really excited about how like
how far players can go with that
all right now you're talking about
glyphs and the Paragon system so let's
talk more about those Paragon boards oh
let's do it okay Paragon boards so we've
uh we talked a bit about Paragon in the
past you know we've shown picture the
board just like this and we're showing
you things like hey look look here's
normal node this is the way you're going
to earn like five willpower you know uh
but that's not all this board is about
you know there's a lot of other there's
a lot of other complexion things to deal
with in here so there's basically four
types of notes to kind of like quickly
uh reprieve some of this information uh
the first of course is normal notes then
we have what you show here is Matic
notes these are different affixes that
you can collect over the course of time
usually they're like a little bit more
difficult to find a direct like version
of on items so like something like this
for example crackling energy uh damage
so there's a so that's a that's a a
sorceress of like a Lightning Lightning
spec Source ability or passive
effectively where uh she'll occasionally
be crackling out damage to nearby
Targets you can now boost that by
finding this particular magic node which
kind of might eventually unlock other
build speed to kind of go and Chase it
after but then there are rare notes
which is on the next side
and uh here okay so there's a some
information here
uh rare nodes have a pretty powerful
effect right off the bat you know and
but then on top of that there's this
this bonus effect down below that you
can you can sort of see where on this
one it is yeah another 60 damage to
Elites if you reach a certain amount of
dexterity for your character so the
point here is like rare notes on their
own which there's about 10 or more per
board rare nodes are already pretty
powerful generically but then on top of
that if you were able to hit these
thresholds for the uh for the stat
requirements for these uh these rare
notes that is going to make them very
very potent for you indeed and when
you're looking at the board these are
some of the most the most critical
things you'll be thinking about when
you're plotting your path through each
board which you of course there are you
know a number of boards available for
your launch and I'm going to be able to
rotate them you'll have to choose how
you want to progress through rare nodes
whether you want to engage with the
legendary notes or not this is a really
important thing yeah one other one other
bit about this just because it's easy
for me to forget about is that when
you're going from Paragon board to
Paragon board like in the first board
this might be the cost but then when
you're looking at the second board that
you're progressing through those
requirements are actually are going to
go up so it's not in your interest to go
like run from board to board just unlock
as many of these as you can directly
that way you need to spend a little bit
of time into the board and pick the ones
you really want because the next board
you unlock to get more rare nodes of
different types those be a little more
expensive to unlock those bonus effects
the thing I think is really interesting
about these is when I the the way that I
look at the board right when I open a
paragon board the first thing I do is go
and look at the rare the nearest rare
nodes to me to my where I'm starting
right and then I see I look at the the
requirements for those bonuses and then
I start looking at the normal nodes I'm
like oh okay well I'm pretty close to
the dexterity required here through my
gear are there some dexterity nodes that
I could hit on the way here that would
take me over it and you know how much do
I care about that particular bonus then
I'm you know comparing it to the other
ones and I'm thinking about that so the
the normal nodes actually become sort of
a path that you're trying to take to
turn on these bonuses absolutely and
that's not all there's one more node
type as well and then we're gonna get to
back to normal notes just a second so
then we have our legendary notes so
every one of the boards for each of the
classes has a legendary node somewhere
on it and these are really really
powerful uh powers like you'd expect
they are a Legendary Power effectively
unique to the Paragon board system for
that class and for the whatever that
particular board is trying to conveys
its overall build type so these are
really really powerful things to go and
collect but they're actually not the
most powerful thing this is just an
additional extra powerful ethics you can
kind of apply to your character but you
kind of do this in concert with other
things you're looking for like I
mentioned the rare notes and I also
talked before about glyphs and we're
going to talk about that next so when
you basically as you're going through
the board they're going to be these
sockets that you can unlock and the
sockets are going to be sitting adjacent
to a number of other regular nodes now
the way that glyphs work is you're going
to put them into one of these sockets
and they are going to be affecting
nearby nodes and also fueled by other
nearby nodes so if you hit certain
thresholds inside out some of the glyphs
you're also going to unlock powerful
bonuses they're going to other always
also effect on nearby nodes at the same
time and and as I mentioned before Glitz
can be leveled up pretty high they
continue to grow the radius of the
affected nodes as you level up through
certain tiers I mean they can affect
larger and larger areas and the boards
are not symmetrical in nature as you're
progressing through because the player
can rotate their board and choose which
gate they actually want to uh to enter
from uh you have to like kind of choose
from board to board which where are the
sockets on this board are they near the
stats I really want for this glyph
because you know this glyph is gonna be
fueled by you know dexterity nodes
within range of the glyph effect and
it's going to do additional the Critical
Strike damage whatever it's going to do
for me as a result that's a really
really important choice to make because
all the boards have different
configurations different socket
locations and different things near
those sockets you have a lot of
interesting decisions to think about
like where you actually want to invest
your time and how does it matter like
how does it feel to do this relative to
the rare nodes you might need on that
board from a different board instead
like fun decisions for players to make
as they're going through we want we want
ultimately to feel like the Paragon
person allows for like two you know
incinerate Focus burn type sore
resources do you feel like they've got
very different paths to the Paragon
board different decisions to make even
if all their skill choices are identical
yeah it's something that you know we've
talked about a lot with Diablo Forest
the idea that even if you have uh you
know let's say incinerate is a powerful
sorcerer build uh for you know
um and and you want to play incinerate
you're not going to necessarily be the
same uh have exactly the same uh Loadout
as another incinerate sorcerer that's
right one thing I found really cool
about the Paragon system that I didn't
realize at first is that every Paragon
board is almost like a paragon class
like a specialization class where it's
all built around a certain theme fantasy
play style
um and it all revolves around that that
Central or off-central legendary node
and then the the rares kind of support
that same theme and it extends to the
blues so like on a necromancer like oh
this board is like the pure Summoner uh
fantasy and this one is the the the
blood Mage and looking at it that way
really like made it uh very cool for me
to be able to explore okay you know I
can merge these two together I'm gonna
go like bone and and blood and just
further uh yeah explore and dive into
that that specialization yeah
you know there's a 220 Paragon points
that players are able to have by the
time they finish leveling up their
Carriage at level 100. uh we want those
choices to feel like they've got meaning
individually players can uh can respect
those choices that they want for gold
cost uh we want to be able to play with
this system to be able to like kind of
experiment with different ideas as they
go but importantly we want them to feel
like that the choices they made for the
220 matter great deal to their overall
performance
yeah
yeah super fun
I think no but yeah